Britain's Prince Harry is testifying in
London's high court for a second day in
his civil case against mirror group
newspapers the parent company of the
Daily Mirror on Tuesday he became the
first UK Royal to enter the witness box
since 1890. he accused the Tabloid press
of destroying his adolescence and
relationships Harry alleges that at
least a hundred articles published over
20 years contained information obtained
through illegal means like phone hacking
Charlie Angela joins us now from outside
the high court in London Charlie I
understand Prince Harry has now arrived
absolutely just ahead of his arrival we
saw crates of documents being wheeled in
his rival was very Swift short distance
from the car to the door obviously not
stopping uh for the journalists in their
droves waiting outside and in the next
10 minutes he'll be taking that witness
stand and will be under scrutiny for his
claims that between 1996 and 2010 the
mirror group newspapers published 140
articles about him that he believed used
information gained illegally either
through phone hacking or through private
investigators now 33 of those articles
have been considered for this case the
lawyer for the mirror group Andrew Green
went through 20 of them yesterday so
we're expecting him to drill down on the
details of those remaining 13 articles
and essentially trying to unpick Harry's
argument
um what he is repeatedly doing is saying
how do you know that the mirror group
were guilty of any unlawful Behavior
because a lot of the information they
these articles was already available in
the public domain Harry's response said
it's his understanding that mirror group
journalists were using a legal means to
gain exclusive angles on these existing
stories to try and push the story on in
some way that is Andrew Green repeatedly
said the problem here is proof and at
the moment there has been none so we
expect the defense to continue to try
and dismantle his claims they'll have
him for a couple of hours at the start
then the prince's lawyers will get a
couple of hours with him and if there is
time we could see some witnesses from
the mirror group themselves maybe even
the Royal editor Jane Kerr Charlie I
want to take you up again on what you
were telling me last hour that the
mirror group has really lawyered up for
this case as you would expect them to of
course and that Harry is being
interrogated in court by a man known as
the Beast
[Music]
yes and Andrew Green is one of the best
barristers in the business he is a
king's Council so essentially he is one
of the Council of Harry's father at the
endocrine very Antiquated uh system that
we have here obviously not representing
him in some way but less of a beast
yesterday more of a kind of
well-mannered battering ram repeatedly
drilling into the prince's foundational
planes that a legal activity was uh was
involved asking repeatedly for evidence
there were no knockout punches no
um you know fireworks no cross you know
words given the prince did remain very
calm very composed pretty confident a
little weary at times five hours of
being grilled would be would be hard for
anyone and at one moment he did say that
his mind had gone blank but he seemed to
kind of gain confidence as the hours
went on he was repeatedly
um asked you know the question like how
how do you know that these journalists
were guilty and his answer was ask the
journalist but in this case none of the
mirror group journalists will be put on
trial will be in the witness stand as
Harry is Harry has said that changing
the culture of the media in this country
is his life's work this is not about
financial gain and he has already had
one apology from the mirror group for
sending a private investigator to follow
him into a nightclub in 2004 and
subsequently print an article about that
night but one apology is not enough for
him he wants an admission of guilt
across the board and a mission that this
was the culture that was Rife it was not
the action of a few Rogue journalists
and this is not his only trial he's
taking both other tabloid Publishers to
task in separate cases all right Charlie
Angela thank you very much and a
sterling job I should add of not letting
yourself get thrown off by that Heckler
who's having him or herself a great day
apparently and enjoying himself out
there outside the courtroom thank you
very much we could hear him or her
Charlie thank you so much for your
reporting